the dirt roads wind up this mountain of
refuse made of four and a half million
tons of garbage trucks come from all
corners of Delhi bringing a further
eight thousand tons of waste per day
this garbage is the only source of
income for around 500 waste collectors
activists Vinland Oh JA wants to help to
marginalize people who eke out an
existence here so we are at the landfill
that's where the trucks are getting
dumped if you see there's a huge dumping
and as soon as that dumping takes place
boys run after that to collect some some
garbage these are tiny kids as and you
know most of them are 10 12 14 year olds
many of them are younger than that
they're all these collectors they're all
rag pickers who try to really make a
living out of this the waste pickers of
gossip or serve an important function
they salvaged recyclable material that
would otherwise be lost forever there's
hardly any recycling that is done by the
government in the sense if there's any
recycling that is only done by the rack
because if you see this they segregate
the garbage they segregate things and
sell it in the informal market in a way
there's nothing in terms of this
management other than transportation
these rickety trucks that you see that
is what is the government effort and
that's it
the kivati wallah a term meaning junk
dealers are experts at recycling right
next to the landfill they sort the items
they've salvaged before selling them
elsewhere in bulk it's so unfortunate
that we have these poor people who are
doing this but imagine if they were not
doing it who would be taking care of our
environment so I consider these rag
pickers as the great green warriors who
don't get recognition for their
environmental work they are really doing
a big service to the environment and our
planet a couple of years ago of him
Linda saw the huge potential involved he
was determined to find a way of
literally revaluing the material a
concept he calls upcycling that's the
philosophy behind the green the gap
project turning trash into fashion and
opening up new opportunities for the
waste collectors
green the gap is already selling its
goods to customers worldwide a creative
way of making India's growing consumer
society more aware of recycling